Delta Airlines is entering into an
exclusive partnership with
california-based Joby Aviation to offer
zero emission airport to City transfers
in electric aircraft in an effort to
invest in a sustainable shuttle solution
Delta plans to begin rolling out the
service in New York and Los Angeles in
the next couple of years after an
initial upfront Equity investment of 60
million dollars Delta will pour up to
140 million dollars more into Joby as
further Milestones are achieved that
investment locks Delta into an exclusive
five-year partnership in the U.S and the
UK with the startup whose electric
vertical takeoff and Landing aircraft or
evtols will operate as part of the Delta
Network designed to solve The Last Mile
Transportation problem evtol aircrafts
promise quick quiet and clean
transportation in and around cities
after flying more than one thousand test
flights Joby was the first evtol company
to be granted a G1 stage 4 certification
basis for its aircraft by the FAA and
recently received its part 135 air
carrier certification while Delta's
exclusive partnership with Joby is
unique other major U.S airlines also see
evtols as the future of airport to City
shuttle services last year United
Airlines forged an agreement with
california-based evtol manufacturer
Archer Aviation making a 10 million
dollar pre-delivery payment for 100
aircraft and just last month United
announced a 15 million dollar investment
in Eve a Brazilian subsidiary of Embraer
with a conditional purchase agreement
for up to 400 four-seater flying taxi
aircraft United said that the first
deliveries from Eve are expected as
early as 2026. foreign